good morning john i mean i started out
your video yesterday and i was like
there's no way this is going to be
interesting predicting the future from
eight days ago that's just not long
enough
for this to be an interesting exercise
but it turns out
it was hugely interesting but before we
get too deep here let's see how your
predictions went
i can be fairly confident that on your
today
it is unseasonably warm in indianapolis
not really it was like three degrees
warmer than usual so i'm gonna call this
one a mist
understandably though it is of course
unseasonably warm on most days in most
places like you could think of 2020 as
one of the warmest years in the last
hundred or
you could think of it as one of the
coolest years in the next hundred
the number of newly diagnosed covid
cases in the united states was higher
yesterday than it was a week earlier
probably by around 10 to 12 percent so
week-to-week we went from 41
601 new cases to 45791 which is an
increase of almost
exactly 10 so that's a win for you
except it's more of a win for the people
who do epidemiological modeling except
it's
more of a loss for everyone and i can
predict about how many people are gonna
buy
this pizza john shirt today probably
around 40. well we blew that one out of
the water we sold more than 95 of those
shirts which is a great example of how
we imagine the future affecting the
future
which is a thing that happens what
happened in afc wimbledon's game against
swindon town i
think we might eke out a draw john afc
woman had a single shot on target
during their game with swindon town and
it went in the goal
and was the only goal scored in the game
which means afc woman beat the town
and you're now in 10th place i know
there's a presidential debate upcoming i
suspect that in your present
that's being much discussed this was a
great prediction john it turns out that
because of kovid
uh we were going to have a a virtual
town hall debate where the two
candidates wouldn't be in the same place
but donald trump didn't want to do that
so he dropped out and then joe biden
was like i'm going to do the town hall
by myself then donald trump was like
okay i'm gonna do a different town hall
but at the exact same time why at the
exact same time i
i don't know maybe because donald
trump's favorite debate format is
talking at the exact same time as his
opponent
the whole time i suspect the news of my
morning will feel like
the very distant past this morning the
main news was that the president of the
united states has been hospitalized for
coving
and you are right somehow that is not a
big deal
in our minds anymore instead the vitally
important thing that we're talking about
now is how congress is
ramming through a supreme court justice
instead of i don't know
thinking about covet relief maybe and i
predict that we will feel like there is
cause for alarm and i also predict that
there will
be cause for alarm john there is and
continues to be cause for alarm we also
talked in your video about
unknown unknowns and how the pandemic
was one of those
and i disagree with you i think the
pandemic was a
known unknown a thing that we know could
have happened
unknown unknowns are things like the
fact that
mask wearing could be politicized you
can look back in hindsight and be like
well i could have seen that that would
be a thing
and like maybe if somebody asked you
like could mask wearing be politicized
you would have said yeah yeah maybe it
could but no one would have thought to
ask the question
that's an unknown unknown and our lives
and our history
are governed by unknown unknowns the
rise of social media
the mere existence of climate change the
internal combustion engine at one time
all of these things
were unknown unknowns and looking at
today from eight days ago which is not a
long time ago
has provided a surprising amount of
insight first the thing we're caught up
in now isn't the thing we're gonna be
caught up in next week which doesn't
seem true
like it doesn't but it is also there is
just a ton
about today that we don't know like we
like to think that
today is the thing that we know the best
but no the thing that we know the best
is like
a year ago and finally just a great deal
has happened
uh it's helped me realize that a great
deal has happened and continues to
happen
and all of it has been for the species
ultimately survivable john i'll see you
tomorrow